KEVIN FEIGE
We always love doing the
unexpected with Scott Lang.
Ant-Man is arguably the character
that is the most underestimated.
Ant-Man became the key to saving
the universe in Avengers: Endgame.
So, carrying that tradition,
we thought, well, let's use this film
to kick off Phase 5.
PAUL RUDD
It's been almost a decade now
that I've been playing this part.
I've loved it and I feel protective
of Scott Lang and Ant-Man.
It's really nice coming back. I still
kinda can't believe that I'm sitting there
and it's like, wow, there's Michelle
Pfeiffer and there's Michael Douglas.
DR. HANK PYM
I just saved eight bucks.
SCOTT LANG
God, I admire you.
PAUL RUDD
It's really nice not to get used
to working with legends.
JANET VAN DYNE
You're sending a signal down
to the Quantum Realm?
[Screams]
CASSIE LANG
Where are we?
JANET VAN DYNE
It's a secret universe beneath ours.
MICHELLE PFEIFFER
Janet has been very quiet about
her time in the Quantum Realm.
Maybe would've, you know,
made different choices. [Laughing]
JANET VAN DYNE
There's someone I never told you about.
KANG THE CONQUEROR
This place isn't what you think.
EVANGELINE LILLY
Kang the Conqueror is terrifying
and if there ever was a maniac loose
in the Quantum Realm, it's him.
JONATHAN MAJORS
Playing Kang the Conqueror is such a gift.
KANG THE CONQUEROR
Your reality.
Everything you're holding onto.
I know how it ends.
JONATHAN MAJORS
This is the beginning,
and he cannot be contained.
[Screams]
PAUL RUDD
Something like this,
which is so transportive
and visually striking,
People should really
see it in a movie theater.
EVANGELINE LILLY
You want it to be as big and
as visceral and consuming as possible.
PAUL RUDD
Audiences are going to watch this and
go I can't believe this is happening.
It's going to be bonkers.
SCOTT LANG
It's like we're camping.
CASSIE LANG
We've never been camping.
SCOTT LANG
But we've always talked about it.
♪♪